pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing
company dedicated to making the very
best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6 built to
wear
not to wear out visit grip6.com
pogchimps
[Music]
sorry i'm vibing right now to epic tunes
whatever you need to do to prepare this
is my preparing
oh god okay cool so we got to starting
off with the white pieces
michelle with the black pieces she is
starting off with the sicilian do you
like the system that she chose for
beginners
i think it is going to be i feel like
she's
learned the moves you know not only is
she playing the sicilian
i'm sure she actually knows how to play
the sicilian too because
with just how much effort and fracture
she's put in she's smiling she seems to
be
you know pretty confident uh with this
opening and d5 she's already taking a
little bit of control in the center and
tubbo
is actually going to be he's gonna stop
bopping his head he was we saw him quite
visibly cad jamming now now he's gonna
pause a little bit
oh she's hovering the bishop hovering
the rook now
f5 and that's going to be up a full rook
for michelle if she sees it
oh no she's going through every single
piece though that's the good news
we might land on the f-bond for sure and
let's say that tubbo doesn't see f5
let's pretend it didn't exist because
you know that's what's been happening so
far
we're just gonna roll with it um another
idea that he would have to
have i guess is to just develop his
queen and his rook this is what we think
of usually as the basics
um otherwise it's a hard position to
play because it's so closed off
michelle is gonna struggle with that
bishop on c8 so he is
doing oh no he blundered a rook i was
gonna say he's doing the principles
but they're not good here oh no
now the question is does michelle see
either f5
or queen takes e4 f5 as possible
is up for grabs for the fourth fifth
move
half the game yeah but you know
sometimes when you have
oh she plays it oh but here queen c3 is
actually a move that's really good i
just don't
know okay all right
you gotta think of queens
oh okay i can move my horse there and
threaten the queen
so then the queen has to move and then i
can sacrifice
my horse then i can damn it no i moved
my queen i now can't get the check
ah what check did he want
um that's a good question
the other problem is if he plays 95 the
rook on e4 is hanging but it's hard to
see i do like the fact that he saw
knight e5 at least
it's a good idea wait a minute he sees
that
let's do that they move that pawn i take
that pawn it's mate
so then they wouldn't yank
oh i'm so happy that your tactics
coaching paid off
do you think it's better to take the
night or try to run here if you're
trying to survive
i think if she's gonna go for a stalling
tactic king h8 is probably better but at
this point she might as well take the
knight and hope
she can oh okay so she has gone for the
stalling tactic however
um she is down a piece as of the moment
and
toppo can choose to just move the night
away yeah maybe we should take a look at
double let's see what he's thinking
since he
finally has the upper hand in this game
um
he has to be a little bit careful though
because his knight is under attack
i think he's giving himself a pep talk
but tomorrow you don't have that much
time
[Music]
you mean you haven't ever tried karaoke
during a chess game
i should probably say if this is down
although yeah sometimes you're right
nemo
yeah i mean i you know what tubbo was
very happy and michelle was also very
happy at the start of the game oh my
gosh okay it is
czech and the rook on e1 is protected
but if he moves his knight or something
like that okay no no no i there's always
that last trick
right it's never over till it's over
yeah for sure
and he hasn't jumped out of his chair
too i'm just like watching him he's like
he's done a whole
workout over there oh my gosh this is
really impressive
um you know i love there's still many
ideas
so yep it's never over until it's over
guys
so if he's trying to if she's trying to
get a stalemate here
she should try to go for something like
f4 yes
oh my gosh if he pushes g4
or he takes okay so now she has h4 and
h5 these are the two squares he does
he has still once this this event though
oh no
h5 if she pushes h5 next move
that would be incredible to try and
trick
tubbo i do want to mention um instead of
playing gtx f4 there was actually
checkman and one with
rook to a5 oh he's going for the
he's going for it awesome wow all right
there is uh checkmating two with rook g5
and rook takes h6 there's one still mini
move here that would be if double plays
bishop to
d8 hopefully he does not yep and holds
that square that's the one way
to can draw i don't think he's gonna
play it it'd be really cute if he plays
h4 for something to take and then
checkmates but
we're not you know going for aesthetics
we just want to see some clean results
there's you can play anything and
black's just in zug's one
um and then all right yep there you go
beautiful
yeah you're right anything is a win here
anything except that one there's a team
oh yeah of course about there's maiden
one
all right and the first game yes
taken by tuppo in this match played very
very
and we got michelle starting off with a
london system
who taught her this nemo um is it
possibly andrea
i don't know uh andrea maybe but i i
michelle has had a ton of coaches
and um so i'm guessing somebody else
taught her because we only worked on
some time it's definitely not me
i i do not advocate for people playing
the london
um i am a big fan of e4 first move but
the london is a very good opening
let's maybe take a listen to michelle
and see what she's thinking here because
it could be a critical position
yes yes all right she saw
it nice job michelle
oh no the rook damn it okay oh god oh
but i have a point wait
i don't know she's worrying a little bit
about that but i think she doesn't
maybe she just doesn't realize that it's
just gonna be a straight exchange either
way
she doesn't lose any material yeah i i
think this is good he's creating a pawn
chain he saw the threat he's responding
he
still has his knight in the center that
he will actually have to take with the
rook
after um which might be a little bit
tricky to see
so i think there's a good chance that if
michelle decides to take his knight
if tubble plays d takes e4 too quickly
oh
okay oh wait that's
going to cause some problems here why
why is this
changing the evaluation bar so quickly
well double players
bringing in his queen and his rook to
just kind of go for a
checkmate attack here i do think after
bishop takes f3
um you can't even take on f3 because
after g takes f3
queen to g5 your only move is king of
one and there it will be knight to d2
which actually forks the queen so
and if you go king to h1 of course there
is knight takes f2 which is checkmate so
this is a very rough position for
michelle to be
in and tumble is just going for the
attack so naturally like he he thought
for
like half a second on bishop takes f3
and
the thing about this tactic is it's
obviously a long variation to see
but they're very natural moves so if
michelle decides to recapture
bringing in your queen for a check is
very tempting
and then it'll be up to tubbo to see
once the king moves if he sees that
knight tactic
um yeah i'm i'm curious oh my gosh let's
go to double screen he does see queen g5
double tactics champ you guys
he has not been skipping his daily
puzzles
no he has not time to raise ourselves
it's freedom like you never knew singing
tumble is popping up in a flash you
say my hat is off to you
[Music]
but
okay so let's see if tubble's still
gonna go
i mean he's still totally winning here
checkmate anymore because the king can
escape
the f1 and rook d1 that's very close
whoa
he doesn't need to beat himself up over
that move it was still perfectly fine
oh no okay tubble has made into tumble
stop beating yourself up
okay you guys if he plays queen g5 queen
g2
oh okay let's actually i want to go back
to tubbo i want to see if he realizes
it's made in one
he was so busy being upset are we gonna
see this
oh it's been played he got upset and
then he just slurped his drink no
reaction oh oh there it is
there he even realizes that was fruity
that was brutal i'm sorry oh my god that
was so brutal
i'm so sorry i no
you did awesome oh my gosh apologizing
for that i swear i've never
i've never played chess like this before
i swear
this is a first for me we're gonna ask
you guys a little bit more about your
emotions but we just wanted to show you
a very important part in the first game
michelle kudos to you for being the
first between the two of you to find the
fork on f5
attacking the rook in the night that had
been there for a while and you found it
we were all super proud
thank you i wish i had founded a few
moves earlier
but both of you guys played amazing i'm
was very impressed by queen c3 it was
it's not a very natural move so double
actually what was your
thought process behind uh playing queen
c3 process was like oh
i don't want to lose these two pieces
what can i do panic
and i i thought that oh i've got a
checkmate um
so i guess i'll use that to try to save
the castle
true michelle also you have probably one
of the craziest
resumes of anyone here i mean you were a
professional athlete you went nuts
youtube you're an actress how does
studying chess compare to all the
other challenges you've done it's so
much harder
it's so much harder i mean everyone it's
amazing like everyone prepared so
differently for this
and everyone prepared so well i know
toppo says he doesn't know an opening
but clearly he knows what he's doing
to some degree or there's some secrets
in the steel drum i don't know what's
going on there
um but yes
um yeah it's it's really really hard i
mean
you can prepare so much and then show up
and then
forget everything or remember nothing i
mean
like it it's very stressful um so
much kudos to you guys for doing this
professionally
and tubbo who is obviously on his way to
doing it professionally
yeah what are you going to announce
you're playing for a world championship
title
uh well first off i don't even know what
that is
well so both of you will be playing in
the consolation bracket
and again a lot of the people who made
it to the championship bracket have been
playing chess for longer than you two
so you're going to be able to battle it
out do you guys have any different
strategies
going into that maybe let's start with
tubbo um
uh strategies i like my pins that is the
thing we did in like
the last lesson it's the only thing i've
managed to retain so i'm using the pins
the pins okay that sounds good what
about you michelle
anything you think you're gonna change
with your approach towards the
consolation
pairings yeah i'm going to order an
ukulele and a steel drum
[Music]
literally yesterday i ordered a bat and
a acoustic
uh electro baritone ukulele you should
get one
okay i'm going to get one what
acoustic ukulele but you can hook it up
to an amp but it's baritone
yeah i think maybe gets hello
i feel like tubbo's energy that he gets
from all of his instruments and his
surroundings really go
into his chest well tubbo michelle you
guys were both such good sports and you
played some
really good games the positions today
were very close so we were
commentating and it felt very tough but
we do wish both of you the best of luck
in the consolation bracket thank you so
much